hello everyone
this is the second video
that i am making on the direct path
it's no surprise that
at the end of this year
2020 that i find myself to be
the most enlightened that i've ever been
in my life
i'm extremely grateful
i have dedicated my
entire being
to truth the last
five years
five years ago in 2015
i was playing clash of clans
across three accounts simultaneously
and today at the end of 2020
i am enlightened
this is my story
this channel and
all of the social media accounts
and high level perception
all a paper trail of my story
and how my
impulse for seeking
which is the truest
aspect to our being to
pierce the veil and uncover the truth
of who we really are
was after all this time
successfully achieved
and i'm constantly re-baselining
to make this state
of being more and more
home
and i feel able to now
after all of these
years
competent enough to teach
and specifically the direct
path
if you haven't yet do watch
the direct path number one that first
one
the links in the bio below to that
this is the second one i will continue
making the direct path videos
they will be a cornerstone of this
channel moving forward
modernity
especially can use
the direct path
to
accelerate piercing the veil
and uncovering the true nature
who we really are so
similarly to the first video
on the direct path i will ask you to
please
place yourself in a space
that is conducive to
the intention that we are setting
in this case the attention
the intention we are setting is
for awakening
and also to attain a
non-dual awareness
this means place yourself
in an environment where there is no
noise pollution
where you can sit comfortably
where you are not
having your monkey mind triggered and
wandering off so we can
focus our awareness with some breaths
nice
breathing that involves our diaphragm
very deep
belly breathing
those inhalations and those exhalations
are
life force
calm the monkey mind
focus your awareness on the intention of
awakening
and on the intention of non-dual
awareness
okay
so let's start with
number one
for those of us that
experience deep
suffering or patterns
of life that
cause us to excessively
ruminate in pain
and anger and depression
the first thing we must do is accept
ourself and in order to accept ourselves
we must
identify these patterns of our life
so let's say that once we've identified
that
we are undergoing a process
of entering into negative states
of experience that we want to distance
ourselves from
in the perennial meditation literature
what we would like to do is create what
is called the pause
so creating space
typically through breath
which distances us from that depressive
thought from that
next anger thought from that next
thought of pain and negativity
and we redirect our attention we
redirect
our awareness and our focus
to something else in this case the
breath
it's also highly recommended
to gather more perspectives
once we train our ability to create a
pause
through the breath what we want to do is
we want to gather more perspectives
while we're in that state of breath
like i am whole
i am good i
am happy i am peace
i am bliss
i am already that
and we redirect our attention slowly to
these extra perspectives where we don't
immerse ourself in the depression
the anxiety the pain the negativity
but we hold these new perspectives
that we typically don't
expose ourselves to
so we want to while we breathe
creating the pause
we want to begin exposing ourselves to
new perspectives
happier more blissful more peaceful
more integral perspectives that are not
limited
to that one tiny compressed
negative perspective but open it up
to more perspectives
we want to transcend
and include that pain
we want to
recognize that that negativity that
depression
that pain is serving
us like a drill sergeant
for our awakening and so
we transcend it and include it and we
become wiser
and we're able to express that wisdom
through the stories that we share to
other people so they can also
transcend and include their pain so they
can also
accept themselves and love themselves
and then work their way to this second
step
the second step for shedding layers
is after we have accepted ourself
after we have transcended and included
the perpetual states of suffering which
are acting like a drill sergeant
for awakening we then
identify ourselves as an
onion and we notice that
i'm identifying myself
with my name atlas i'm identifying
myself with my age
i'm 28 i'm identifying myself with my
ethnicity i'm armenian i'm identifying
myself with my location i'm in los
angeles
identifying myself with my role i'm an
entrepreneur
and there's all these layers these 5 10
15 20 plus layers that we put on
ourselves
but what is at the core of that onion we
must ask ourselves
and what happens when we peel those
layers of the onion
one at a time
so that our identity is no longer
associated
with the layers of the onion
but it is now associated
with the pure
bear awareness
that is our true nature
so now we are beginning to pierce
the veil
now that intention
of awakening and non-dual awareness
is really beginning to pick up speed
so
these are things like
analogies that are helpful for us to
understand this
would be the paper
without words
the screen without
the movie
so
we juxtapose awareness
consciousness
as pre-coloration
and with coloration so in this case
with coloration is usually the way that
we engage
with our consciousness and our awareness
it means we are immersed in thoughts
feelings emotions or objects
and that is with coloration so that is
the movie that's on the screen
or those are the words that are on the
page
now pre-coloration
awareness is that pure that bear
that primal awareness so that's the
paper
without any words
that's the screen without
the movie
and practice this
turn off the monitor or the television
and just sit and look at it
the screen without the images
and tap into that process of your pure
bear awareness being
just like that screen
that does not have any images on it
and very similarly when you look at
a page in a book practice this
look at the page with the words
and then look at the paper itself
that the words are written on
and it's just that simple
okay so now
as we shed those layers
we become more and more
used to
this feeling of pure or bear awareness
as home
it's as though we are working the muscle
over time we're doing the reps
of enlightenment and what that's doing
is it's also causing us to become better
and better
at things like the pause
we become ninjas
we become wizards
we become jedis
we are able to both lovingly
and wisely like a mirror
of the absolute highest
morality
be and create that
butterfly effect
so there's a very pragmatic
importance to the intention
of awakening and the intention of
non-dual
awareness a very
very pragmatic and
important
reason for understanding
our true nature for piercing the veil
especially for the people that are
in the positions of greatest
leadership in influence around our
planet
the fortune 500
ceos the united nations general assembly
the united states
congress the 2200 billionaires around
the planet
the 225 000 ultra high net worth
people around the planet one of our most
upstream if not the most upstream malady
that civilization
faces is egoic
levels of consciousness in those
positions of leadership
and so the pragmatic application of
awakening and nondual awareness
is especially for those people in those
positions of leadership
the ability to be of the highest
morality
critical paramount
so pragmatic you become a ninja
you become a jedi
with your family with your friends
with your business partners with your
clients
with the community with the whole world
super pragmatic highest levels of
morality
wisdom love
okay so as we've
become more familiar with doing these
repetitions of making pure
bear awareness more and more of our home
the paper without the words the
screen without the movie
we create that juxtaposition that's
ultimately a unity
but we create the juxtaposition in order
for us to aim to pierce the veil in
understanding our true nature
and then
in this third step
we are asking the question
might this awareness
this pure bear awareness
consciousness that we speak of
might that be eternal
might that be infinite
might that be peace
might that be bliss
existence consciousness bliss might that
be true
and so we begin re-baselining
ourselves to understand that that pure
bear
awareness consciousness
is not only eternal and infinite
and blissful and peaceful
so it was here
before it will be here after
it has always been and will always be
and it never ceases to be
that realization
and then also the realization that that
pure bear awareness and consciousness
is not only the paper or the screen
for me but it's also the paper
and the screen for you
and it's also the paper
and the screen for your family for your
business partners
for your co-workers for your friends
for the community and for the world that
we
all share that awareness
we share that consciousness we
share our being
and that is love
and that is non-duality
there is one source there is one god
there is one infinite creator
and we are that tatvam
asi i and my father
are one wadata
the unity of all being the unity of all
existence the unity of all finding
all eight billion
of us undergoing our own
unique yoga our own unique
hypnosis our own unique union
union with what union with non-duality
union with seeking and union with
finding
finding the one infinite creator finding
god
piercing the veil and understanding that
our
awareness our consciousness in its most
pure bear form
is it that is it
that is the diamond necklace
that is already around our necks
so that becomes self-knowledge of god
that becomes self-knowledge of who we
truly are
and this is another example of the
direct path
again i highly recommend checking out
the first direct path that we did if you
haven't already seen that
also this second direct path here we
will continue making direct path videos
like this
if this
landed and created
a augmentation
congratulations and
revisit the video again
and see if it can continue
helping you and like the video
and subscribe if you haven't and share
the video with other people
that can use this direct path teaching
again we aim to cover all of these
bases in this direct path teaching
from the initial setting
and the initial intention of awakening
and nondual awareness
through accepting ourselves
and getting through those patterns
transcending and including
our pain
creating that pause
gathering more perspectives
and once we get that state of loving
ourselves we recognize those layers to
the onion
and then we slowly shed those layers to
the onion down to the pure
bear awareness down to the paper without
the words down to the screen
without the images and we can practice
this process
by simply powering off the monitor or
the television
we're looking at the page of the book
and just sitting there and being with
the screen
without the image and recognizing that
that is
our pure bear awareness or the page
without the words
is our pure bear awareness
and then undergoing the process of
inquiring into the eternal the infinite
the blissful and the peacefulness
of that pure bear awareness
consciousness and how it is shared
in that being love that being
self-knowledge of god that being
piercing the veil of the true nature of
our existence
and having an embodied anchored
self-realization
of who we truly are that is the direct
path number two
thank you very much i would love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below
on the video
i wish you
to continue with
your journey in the greatest
health and prosperity possible
with that seeking impulse
to pierce the veil
and to understand the true
nature of who we are
thank you
you